In addition to design methods, representations and
validations, there are some other issues that arise with software design.
We already talked about the difference between architectural and
detail design and exactly where that boundary is. Of key importance is
the respective energies we put into designing the functional part of the system
versus dealing with those non-functional constraints. At a more abstract level,
there's the difference between what and how. The specification process deals
with what the system will do. The design process begins to say how we're
going to do it. Finding the right boundary between those two is a key issue. And
finally, what is there about your particular application that is going to affect
the design process? For example, you have some existing resources that you want
to reuse and build in your solution. They can affect the design that you do.